Rick is gonna start us off this hour
Rick is in Texas hi Rick welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show
hey baby thanks for taking my call sure
what's up so I kind of looking for just
some financial advice and also helped me
with a way forward
I'm military and my wife actually filed
for a divorce well I just returned from
a deployment so just trying to get some
advice as far as legal proceedings what
to do with all of our assets and
anything really I'm sorry ma'am thank
you for your service what a nice gift
what a nice gift to come home to ya know
how long you've been serving I've been
in 17 years how long were you deployed
just a little over four months okay so
things weren't good when you left
no sir we actually originally filed for
divorce back in November we kind of work
stuff out at least I thought we did and
then I got it sent on my deployment and
got welcomed with that news right before
I got just telling her I was coming back
so so this one's going through you think
okay all right yeah this ship sailed so
moving forward all right well I've got a
friend that does divorce recovery work
and works through all the emotions and
stuff and said one of the most clear
things that helps me when I'm looking at
this kind of thing is there's all this
emotion all this hurt all this crap in
the air around this situation and yet
divorce turns a marriage into a business
transaction and so once we've called it
once the ship is sailed
then it's down to division of assets
income and children right it's just a
matter of negotiating out the details
and it's just a you know who gets what
it's a business transaction now and
always the emotions and
finger pointing in the hurt and the
heart brokenness and all that gets woven
into the discussion but it really
doesn't change the result that much
because the laws are pretty clear so do
you guys have assets yes sir we have a
house that we have that's currently in
Delaware those renters in it right now
so what will happen to it
so we did initially discuss selling it
but we were looking either now or just
wait until the springtime when the
markets a little more consistent versus
going into the wintertime when sales on
is good especially out in the East Coast
okay all right and so the divorce decree
might declare that the house goes on the
market within a year of the final of
becoming final and I wanted to sold the
proceeds are split yes sir okay anything
else that's the only joint assets that
we have everything else is to her name
now what's that mean you should put
everything in her name I'm happy with
that
you know yeah and her just dead in her
name yes sir okay what is the nature of
that uh she bought a minivan right
before we divorced so we paid actually
we were using your steps paid off all
the debt that we had for her pretty much
but yeah she decided to go the other
direction okay yeah she's not a big fan
of you that happens that's great all
right well so what's your question how
can I help you
so mainly my I think both of our focus
is the kids is the main thing but she
hired a lawyer and I just got served
with the actual papers yesterday and
just wanted to see if there's anything
you would recommend as far as the kids
alimony child support because she
actually is also military she'd she's
actually retiring as of the 28th and she
has a hundred percent VA disability I
don't know if that's um
and that could really factor into that
or just making sure it's you need a
lawyer it's the fair balanced you know
you don't you don't need me you need a
lawyer don't don't go unrepresented with
her having an attorney you need an
attorney and then the two of them can
help you guys understand what the law in
Texas says which is what will apply
because that's where the divorce was
filed and you know what your what your
obligations are under the law for child
support and for anything else and you
know you can work that out but now don't
be walking around thinking that her
lawyers gonna treat you right no you
need representation yesterday so I'm
sorry brother sorry thank you for your
service and I'm sorry that's what was
waiting on you